vous avez parlé quelqu'un de la démarche
que nous allons entreprendre ensemble
oui j'en ai parlé à monsieur l'alouette
c'est un voisin puis j'en ai parlé à mon
fils bien sûr
autrement nous a dit que vous étiez
d'accord de l'accompagner
rich
c'était bien moi je trouve très bien que
les proches soient présentes nous c'est
vraiment essentiel
où
c'est l'appel de souhaiter ce test a
décidé que ça finirait mal ici dit ça
finirait mal
c'est très bien ce que j'ai il faut pas
se raconter d'histoires
ne parlez pas rester comme ça ça me
dérange pas moins fait bien ce qu'il
fait
i
en quête ou cachés pour s'amuser c'est
la chercher des bouées merde
c'est pas parce que tu parles comme donc
l'arrivée que tu as raison qu'est ce
qu'il ya
à la mema est ce que vous pourriez nous
dire si vous avez eu
une belle fille
non